j'accueille tarak ben ammar hervé bailly
chine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on est
très flattée évidemment de vous recevoir
vie vous êtes les normes producteurs
vous aussi tarak traque vous êtes
l'héritier de la dynastie ben ammar qui
a longtemps été associé au site arabe
shalev star ac' bénin qui a longtemps
été associé aux destinées de l'état
tunisien vous est le neveu de l'épousé
de bourguiba
vous avez commencé après études à rome
comme comme assistant de production
le matin vous vous leviez pour aller
voir si les le plein des voiturettes
effet quoi vous êtes vraiment commencé
en barre ensuite vous avez emmené
giorgio cassant en tunisie georges locas
pour la guerre des étoiles il n'avait
pas d'argent et je disais oui à tous les
metteurs en scène de quelle que soit
leur nationalité
une tunisie encore pauvre et qui était
rentré dans le monde de tourisme et je
rencontre georges occase en aéroport et
il me dit est ce que tu as un décor pour
une planète toute manière je disais oui
par principe qui est maintenu
une fois qu'ils étaient là je me démerde
et trouver un accord et la planète de la
guerre des étoiles le premier je vous
parle il ya exactement 30 ans je les
remets dans un village qui s'appelle
tataouine
ouais et la planète tatooine pour les
milliards de fans c'est un petit village
dans le sud tunisien qui a beaucoup plu
à giorgio castres et depuis georges ou
kas revient tournée mais même plan parce
que ça lui porte bonheur il vient
tourner tous les plans de la guerre des
étoiles de la planète tataouine
même s'il fait le film ailleurs comme ça
a été le cas l'an guerre
dans l'histoire ensuite t'as que j'avais
beaucoup donné avec avec jésus vous avez
produit jésus de nazareth de zeffirelli
la vie de brian des monty python 2
heures moins le quart avant jésus christ
de jean yanne et vous avez distribué le
film de mel gibson ya la passion du
christ j'ai vu aussi des échecs vous
savez du pirate de polanski qui est une
catastrophe pour vous vous avez perdu
combien tarak le dessus au 20 20 25
millions de dollars avait presque autant
que moi un peu moins un peu voulait
rentrer dans les toilettes
mais je les ai récupérées ouais grâce à
un procès historique c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire du cinéma qu'un
producteur étranger de surcroît du
tiers-monde
j'ai fait un procès à la grande major
company universal
ah oui qui a duré dix ans et j'ai gagné
parce qu'il m'avait signé un contrat qui
n'ont pas respecté c'est pour ça que
j'ai perdu l'argent et preuve de la
grande démocratie américaine
j'ai gagné devant un jury populaire
19 millions de dollars bravo un retour
très réussie avec la télévision où vous
êtes associé de berlusconi avec murdoch
avec patrick le lay et tf1 le cinéma
vous êtes associé avec joe delaronde
this maintenant avec les frères
weinstein dans leur nouvelle société qui
l'ont créée après leur départ de miramax
alors vous avez vous êtes l'un des deux
frères weinstein légendes d'hollywood
producteur et distributeur alors
allons-y de pulp fiction reservoir dogs
kill bill sexe mensonges et vidéo cinéma
paradiso la leçon de piano
adieu ma concubine la cité de dieu
shakespeare in love game the new york 10
aviez tort
le patient anglais cdn scary movie les
invasions barbares
et si une fille team
[Applaudissements]
c'est réussi
alors vous arrivés tous les deux de
cannes du festival de cannes vous êtes
trouvé comment le festival harvey ait
fait j'ai trouvé que le festival était
absolument formidable je lis jury ont
fait un excellent choix
la seule décision avec laquelle j'étais
pas d'accord jouer que cet effet ne
cause que réduites au meilleur rôle
féminin toute seule elle n'avait pas
besoin de tout
tout cet aéropage femina autour des arts
ea vous avez déclaré pour moi le
meilleur film réalisé sur los angeles
si chinatown de polanski le meilleur
film réalisé sur new york c'est macadam
cowboy de john schlesinger le meilleur
film de gangsters sait il était une fois
en amérique de sergio leone
tous ces réalisateurs sont venues
d'europe
il faut défendre la diversité culturelle
en europe
c'est rare de la part d'un producteur
américain entendre ça et voyez vous moi
je crois beaucoup à la diversité
culturelle mais en plus saab est
sagement par le passé je le répèterai il
me semble que la france et d'autres pays
doivent justement protéger leur cinéma
contre justement le cinéma muet quand
même six mois je suis américain joue 10
argos commun pourquoi parce que les
américains ne rendent pas français dit
on n'a pas été les avec les émissions
françaises et pourtant l'inversé le rêve
n'a pas présenté de films français en
tant que fille ni à la télévision en
prime femme depuis 40 ans alors comment
où est la justice où l'équité par
rapport aux français anglais ou encore
au cinéma allemand ou espagnol a aucune
justice lat en moi j'adore le cinéma a
dit cinéma chez les voir ce film les 400
coups de françois truffaut shrek c'est
un film érotique
[Musique]
parce que le titre blues for a le blues
la traduction de 400 coups ça faisait
penser au blowjobs ou pipe
alors on a fait quatre des kilomètres
sous la neige pour les voir ce film il
ya que mon frère et moi qui avons vu ce
film parce que tout le monde était déçu
en noir et blanc avec les sous titres
pas une seule fille enfin toujours est
il que huit de mes copains ont quitté le
cinéma en courant en disant allez vous
faire voir les pubs et moi on y rester
et on est tombé amoureux du cinéma
français ce jour-là à l'âge de 10 ans
avec le film de truffaut riz c'est une
leçon d'amour des fonctionnaires alors
qu'il est né à brooklyn dans la banlieue
de new york votre père s'appelait max il
était déjà mentaires il vous a mené tous
les samedis au cinéma il aimait tous les
genres sauf les films de guerre parce
qu'ils avaient combattu pendant la
guerre il fallait plus de lui en parler
de la guerre se joue c'est exactement ça
en effet mon frère et moi on adorait les
films d'errol flynn qui sauvait la
mairie mais mon père ne pouvait pas
supporter ce film il ya un film si pour
moi tout est justifié
c'était il faut sauver le soldat ryan
reste pourquoi parce que jusqu'à ce que
je sois ce film je ne comprenais pas ce
que mon père eisen mais mon père avait
vu justement la guerre elle avait
participé à des patins et c'est pour ça
qu'ils pouvaient pas voir de film de
guerre à moins qu'il ne dise la vérité
est très peu de films d'hollywood de
présenter la réalité oui on en faisait
tout à un film de propagande autour de
la mairie
mais on voyait jamais du sens les balles
ne tuaient jamais personne n'était pas
vraiment la vision réelle de la guerre
en votre mère s'appelle myriam elle est
toujours vivante et elle pense encore
que le cinéma est un job occasionnels et
vous dit qu'elle n'a pas encore perdu
l'espoir que vous deveniez médecin mais
à 81 ans et si quelqu'un a besoin d'une
bonne mère juive elle est là pour ça
elle peut
deyris et les revenus aux jeux
olympiques pour la discipline
je ne plains de tout et s'il ya
quelqu'un qui a un souci
elle peut se faire du souci pour tout le
monde en 1979 vous montez avec votre
frère une société qui s'appelle miramax
du nom de vos parents myriam et max
voilà
et alors vous allez au festival de
cannes au début des années 80 vous
n'avez pas d'argent vous connaissez
personne et vous êtes dans un placard à
balais à l'hôtel majestic
c'était un placard à balais et j'ai
dormi avec mon frère parce que sinon il
y aurait eu toutes sortes de rumeurs à
mon sujet personne ne m'a habité à
brader fine dans le palais des festivals
la pêche la prestation officielle donc
que je suis a filtré comme on faisait un
climat entrer par les portes de sortie
par les issues de secours et en os 6
j'essaie sur les marchés puis les
gendarmes s'est tenu le week ends à
défaut vous quittez la salle c'est lui
qui était juste à côté de moi qui étais
sur un laissez moi tranquille et c'était
c'était sean connery en personne qui
nous faisait défaut
alors que les gens nerveux devant
monsieur bond a dit bon nous on les sait
rester dans la salle et c'était la
première fois que j'ai rencontré sean
connery
vingt ans plus tard j'ai raconté cette
histoire
lorsque j'ai eu l'honneur de lui
présenter un film dans le cadre d'une
film festival de new york et suit
raconté l'anecdote il a beaucoup ri
parce que c'est le genre de personne
qu'il ait laissé des métros
alors voilà donc en 1981 arrive in sync
et son premier festival de cannes et dix
ans plus tard dans un autre festival de
sundance organisé par robert redford
vous repérez sexe mensonges et vidéo de
soderbergh et c'est le début du succès
vous inventez le block busters sur le
film qui marche indépendant oui je sais
pas si j'ai inventé ce ce genre cela
étant moi il me semble que un grand
final a besoin d'être confiné aux
ghettos des films d'art et essai sexe
mensonges et vidéo vous pouvez le voir
dans le monde entre eux il fallait pas
le confiner aux petites salles
le fait qu'un film soit intelligent ne
signifie pas qu'il soit limité
c'est les mauvais films qui devraient
être limitées mais les films
intelligents devrait avoir un large
public au contraire votre autre grande
spécialité harvey c'est la course aux
oscars vous dépenser des millions de
dollars en publicité en soirée spéciale
en cadeau sans parler des coups de fil
avec un acharnement au delà du réel pour
avoir des oscars vous promettez aux
acteurs que citera avec vous ils vont
avoir la petite statuette dorée 250
nomination à ce jour quelque 71 alors il
est pour moi
l'académie les oscars c'est la façon de
commercialiser un bon film finalement ce
dock évidemment on a investi beaucoup de
temps d'efforts là dedans mais
quelquefois il ya un petit film comme
leçon de piano ou frame games
shakespeare in love ou le patient
anglais n'auraient normalement pas
trouvé un grand public à travers le
monde mais c'est évidemment l'eau sera
qu'était le tremplin qui leur a permis
d'apporter au public alors pas
simplement pas nécessairement meilleur
film mais aussi mon meilleur rôle
masculin au féminin
évidemment ça aide énormément un film un
les prochaines heures vous avez
l'afrique à jouer marianne côtier qui a
joué car j'ai vu 20 minutes de ce film à
cannes l'état prestation je suis sûr qu
elle méritera nosca en tout cas elle
sera nominée cotillard dans la vie
devient le piaf ont réalisé par olivier
dahan est produit par ilan goldman alors
on vous reproche quand même harvey un
certain ni respect pour les oeuvres ont
dit que vous coupez que vous remonter
les files les français dit vous vous
appelle d'artagnan à cause du sabre et
on vous appelle aussi six organs harvey
c'est vous ingolstadt de chaleur après
l'émission
je vais vous montrer la version de cinq
heures de game the new york et vous
comprendrez mec et s'il vous arrivait à
tenir trois heures chapeau à alors le
plus grand honneur que j'ai reçu c'est
que martin scorsese dit maintenant la
version de deux heures et demie est la
seule verso qu'il présentera donc lui
donner content il y a que la concurrence
qui m'accusent d'être crs parce qu'ils
sont jaloux mais nous nous disons la
vérité et en disant la vérité en face
nous emportons les palmes d'or les
oscars il a l'habitude de dire la vérité
alors c'est vrai pour un metteur en
scène quand on lui dit son film est long
ouais c'est difficile c'est difficile et
les metteurs en scène sont entourés de
collaborateurs qui n'osent pas paris est
un peu brusque mais souvent essentiels
alors il faut c'est de la rue à tort aux
états unis vous savez conteste les films
sur des publics smic preview sting prévu
avant de les sortir et on apprend
beaucoup et malheureusement il a souvent
raison c'est à dire que la conclusion du
public c'est un peu ce qui l'a anticipé
mais il le fait à la fin avec la
collaboration des metteurs en scène des
producteurs est ce que est ce que
patrice chéreau est content de la
version cours
de la reine margot vous avez distribué
aux états unis hyphen qui s'appellera
qu'il est très satisfait et hamilton
je crois que la seule chose qui a
empêché le film d'être un peu plus
grands succès encore c'est que johnny tu
es censé venir en amérique pour faire la
promotion
or l'avait des problèmes personnels n'a
pas besoin mais c'était là c'était une
déception qu'ils appellent des pistols
mais toutes les critiques étaient très
bonne sur la reine margot et on estime
que c'est l'un des grands films français
états unis et c'est la version courte
c'est vrai mais comme il a dit qu'il
était très content de voir ce film lui
en tant que juif et c'est un soulagement
de voir des protestants à des catalyst
ils ont trop fait d'avoir des les juifs
qui sont assassinés s'était infiltré
très relaxant alors on vous reproche
aussi d'être terriblement dur en affaire
harvey il ya une phrase qui courent sur
vous à hollywood qui dit si vous ne vous
êtes jamais fait baiser par miramax si
vous n'avez jamais travaillé avec eux
haiping pathom et leur game in view
alors là encore ceux qui disent ça
généralement se cachent derrière
l'anonymat
souvent ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas
de succès est-ce que vous avez le nom de
l'auteur de cette citation non y'a que
les lâches qui diront des choses
pareilles en 1993 ou vendait donc à
disney la société miramax web ce qui
s'est passé c'est que tous les metteurs
en scène
découvrez tout le talent mais nous
n'avions pas les moyens
malgré notre succès nous n'étions quand
même une petite maison de production
donc la chaîne qui a réalisé my left
foot nous a quittés pour aller à une
berceau pascal guilbault et mieux alors
évidemment on aurait proposé davantage
si on avait pu mais nous ne pouvions pas
dossier quand nous nous sommes rendus à
dézoner ils ont
décidé de nous donner les moyens de
travailler avec ces réalisateurs is hot
et très bien aux as par un des sept
premières années de la collaboration
avec des années ont été excellentes on a
fait part fiction ils se sont un peu
mêlé de sa maison que l'on pouvait
naviguer assez bien et on a fait
transporter hing on a fait beaucoup de
films très controversé mais après dogma
et fahrenheit nine eleven où ils ont
refusé
lord of the rings bon là ça a commencé à
mal tourner disney vous a refusé le
seigneur des anneaux j'avais développé
un projet avec peter jackson
j'ai mis 10 millions de dollars pour
développer toute la technologie des
tonnages en nouvelle-zélande pour
pouvoir faire ce que vous avez vu à
l'écran les trois scénarios ont été
développés par nous j'allais voir des
semis g 10 pieds de jackson five trois
films il nous faut 180 millions $ parce
que j'avais un plafond mais je ne
pouvais pas aller au delà de 75 millions
c'est tout ce que je peux déplacer quand
j'étais aux commandes et j'aurais dit il
m'en faut plus je voulais faire trois
ont dit non non seulement on n'y croyait
pas seigneur des anneaux mais ils m'ont
dit je conserverai une partie des
recettes en tant que producteur veilleux
et garder les sous puisque je n'y
croyais pas c'est comme ça que franchit
donc ça plus faranah et le film de
michael moore vous avez quittez donc
votre association avec disney ils ont
produit par night qui a gagné à cannes
michael moore et disney a refusé de le
distribuer parce que il attaque et bien
sûr le président bush son frère et lui
ont sorti un chèque ont payé le film
l'ont acheté quelle erreur pour disney
et l'on distribue dans le monde entier
avec le succès que vous connaissez
courageux
alors que l'équité donc votre
association avec disney et vous avez
monté une nouvelle société qui s'appelle
the weinstein company vous disposez d'un
milliard de dollars donc ça laisse
rêveur soit pour faire des films
ils ont un milliard de dollars évitant
le cinéma ils ont levé un milliard de
dollars donc associé avec tarak ben
ammar est assez beau d'ailleurs de voir
le juif de brooklyn qui était associé
avec le le musulman de de tunis est
assez jolie histoire
1 c'est la bible c'est la bible avec
vous il ya des français et des européens
il ya tf1 il ya patrick le lay qui est
associé avec vous il ya lvmh aussi qui
est associé avec vous c'est assez voilà
c'est le cuménique finalement des
japonais un chinois un c'est vraiment
une compagnie internationale est très
européenne
ouais tout en étant américaine avec
barbet ravis qu'ils détiennent 50% de la
compagnie 50 ou 51 51
oui un bug in shore on est la neige or
voilà donc parmi les premiers films de
cette société il y en a un qui s'appelle
yang hannibal le jeune hannibal qui est
un puits quoi elle de la fameuse série
du silence des agneaux avec gaspard
ulliel alors c'est très gonflé d'avoir
pris gaspard ulliel
mais ça c'est la dcri de tracas c'est
lui qui l'a découvert bien sur le
terrain qu'en tant que producteur du
film a une dernière à karim m'a présenté
un casting avec cinq minutes aux
questions qu'ils avaient été tous les
acteurs américaine même les plus grands
nous voulait se roule pas j'ai vu ce
casting
c'est absolument extraordinaire je gare
sera très très loin
or vie tarak nous a dit tout à l'heure
que vous disiez toujours la vérité donc
on va voir on va faire une interview
hollywood swiss ait entre basique in
sting pts 2 et marie antoinette lequel
vous détestez le plus fatigué 1,5 tout
ça c'est le le plus horrible des faits
c'est incroyablement mauvais voilà rires
connais tu as quand même de très bonnes
choses dedans mais qu'est-ce que sofia
coppola doit encore apprendre alors
atteint servier cobras à sofia coppola
est une bonne mais réalisatrice elle
avait cette vision la critique n'a pas
suivi mais le public semble l'avoir
suivie jusque au mans et il met le fait
de comparer marie antoinette est basée à
5,2 à des plumes les films jamais
réalisés
au-delà du pire si vous voyez ce film
l'argent devrait aller vous voulez la
vérité
à part ça ça m'a vu les avis qu'est ce
que vous n'aimez pas à hollywood
allez-vous d'être un club fermé des deux
me suis dit ce serait plus tout comme
rome à l'époque ancienne
il fallait de spartacus en quelque sorte
pour déclencher une révolte
vous avez les grosses médor et des
vitraux studio qui sont identiques mais
s'intéresse davantage à l'argent ce
n'est qu'une question d'argent de gros
soucis alors si les gens disent qu'on
est dur c'est eux qui nous ont précédés
studio qui nous ont endurci et le fait
que ce soit d'ailleurs c'est ça qui nous
a permis race de les combattre parce
qu'attention avant ni personne ne
pouvait rivaliser avec les studios des
petits réalisateur les petits signer à
sochaux écrasés maintenant ils ont plus
de pouvoir d'achat parce que nous avons
été dur quel est l'acteur à hollywood
qui mérite plus 20 millions de dollars
par film
la plupart d'entre eux qu'est ce que les
français font mieux que les américains
au cinéma français ont un cinéma plus
intime du personnel longue date le
spectateur voit son intelligence l'atc
d'être les acteurs sur notre légende
personnages des scénarios et c'est
d'être à des gens et on n'est pas
condescendant par rapport au public
cd relève le niveau alors qu'avez vous
pour attirer un maximum de public on
nivelle par le bas alors que tant que la
tendance allait dans le sens et les
comédiens sont très dures en général
j'aime en une copie les comédies
françaises
weber ou les grands alors que pitois
hollywood [ __ ] manier bousculer on va
payer
je laisse j'estime qu'un avis qu'est-ce
qui vous a énervé récemment chez tom
cruise iphone fait sa religion qui sont
le sait c'est tout match et thomas est
un petit peu étroit d'esprit c'est
quelqu'un de très sympa que je connais
très bien
on a vécu le même immeuble dans l'otan
nous sommes les amis mais cette année le
temps du choix qu'il a pris peur fermé
mais il va se rouvrir je pense dans les
années à venir c'est ce que je prendrai
beaucoup voir de film avec tom cruise si
ma production m'enfin c'est un très bon
acteur
le yagha ce parc a révélé qu est-ce que
n'importe quelle actrice a de plus que
nicole kidman
moi j'ai fait sept films avec nicole
kidman y compris le film pour lequel
allenby nascar et d absolument pas
d'être extraordinaire sous tous ses
aspects et films comiques sérieux nicole
kidman a de bonnes choses mais tout ça
s'use email peut accepter à 15 millions
$ d'un studio
et puis finalement elle travaillera
gratuitement sur des as aux que je fais
avec elle ou encore une fois un petit
projet elle est très généreuse qu'elle
filme avez vous regretté de produire
être prêt à porter avec robert altman
mon problème c'est que j'ai jamais
rencontré marché le meurtre altman l'a
mis avec ce trailer ncaa ratings et j'ai
oublié de faire mon job de producteurs
je passais mon temps avec marcello toute
la journée jeux la compagnie de
matériaux soi il m'a emmené à déjeuner
raconter toutes les anecdotes sur
fellini des sica et tous les héros de
mon enfance pendant huit semaines j'ai
oublié mon travail alors aux rebelles
mènent m'a dit mais je te vois jamais tu
passes tout autant avec marcello alors
j'ai pas pu vraiment participer au fil
[Musique]